it's time to supercharge your summer
movie season
i'm britt morin founder and ceo of
britain co and i've teamed up with dq to
welcome you to fandango's family movie
night
today we're going to be making the
cutest little capes for the little
heroes in your family
using stuff you probably already have at
home
it's time to watch those superhero
movies in style
alright let's get started by collecting
everything you'll need for this project
first in order to fit your child you'll
need roughly an 18 by 24 piece of
felt and some accessorizing felt colors
so you can make your fun shapes and
patterns
then you'll need fabric scissors fabric
glue or a glue gun
a pen for tracing and a couple pieces of
velcro to make it stick
all right first step is to cut the shape
of your cape you're going to take
your biggest piece of fabric and cut out
a large
trapezoid so i've already cut one side
here
and i'm going to measure this other side
just by my eyes
and make a diagonal line all the way
to the end next you're going to make a
u-shape along the back so that you have
little tabs that can act like the neck
straps
all right next you're going to cut out
different types of shapes from your
colored felt you can make stars
lightning bolts
even an earth and then decide which one
you want to glue onto your cape
i'm gonna go with this lightning bolt
just use your fabric glue
to spread out along the felt
and place it wherever you want
as a final step you're going to take
your two velcro tabs
and put one underneath
your first tab here on the felt
and the other is going to go on top
of your second it fits perfectly right
now your little one can take on the
world
treat your kiddo and yourself to an oreo
fudge brownie blizzard from dq
next time you're out and about thanks
for watching and be sure to check out
fandango now for more superhero films
for the whole family